hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play don't
starve I know it's been a while since I
did an episode of this but I got
distracted by other things like Oh boobs
and stuff and I got desire you know me
okay anyway but I got distracted by
other games for a while there and I am
back and you guys informed me that the
divining rod doesn't actually show me
the direction of maxwell's portal I know
I good cold it's so cold anyway it's
still winter oddly enough we've been
that in winter for way longer than I
thought we would and you guys are
raining on my parade left and right when
I'm trying to get this done but I love
you all the same that's right you heard
me right mark of our love's you mock
about lives you soo much more give I
love you did the okay I'll give it okay
alright enough of the love we don't have
time for love we're trapped in the
wilderness we need to find Maxwell's
door so that we can move on so basically
I had to track back over here because I
was running out of food and I wasn't
getting anything in the forest so and I
don't have a pot to cook those monster
meats in so basically I had to make do
with what a hand don't judge me I try I
try so hard you all just go think I'm
not smart but I am smart I know what is
best to bad doctor markiplier had that
fatal heart attack and died Elzy might
be able to help me out here cuz this guy
only has a PhD and not doing well at
surviving this niss obviously well this
guy is a doctor right doctor
something--some his name is not Maxwell
but I've kind of forgotten what his name
is
poopie it's cold weird my why is my heat
stone not eating maybe I need to put the
heat stone by my fire girl here maybe I
need to like put the heat stone by the
fire and that would help cook it up a
bit maybe maybe it can only portable
eyes some heat I'm not sure but let's
drop the heat stone by there maybe it'll
heat up a bit soak in some heat kind of
hard to serve out there haha
I worked I can't believe that worked is
it ready to go
arise coop oh now it's red hot cool cool
beans I picked it up at the exact right
time as when I needed it good for me I'm
like a pro at this game or some I am uh
some kind of amazing aren't I
hey everybody aren't I just the best
aren't I just adorable to you and you my
pinch my cheeks enjoy a job with that no
no that no time for that we're in a
rough survival situation we still need
to collect a bit more food because I
know we don't have enough because
basically I'm just gonna spend a lot of
this time running around trying to find
a way out which I don't know how easy
it's gonna be to make that happen
but we're still gonna try I haven't
managed to find any gold at all so I
don't know what's going on with that but
c'est la vie
que sera sera some glob of blue Kapoor I
don't know I don't speak blue Gork hell
is this thing I'm gonna be wandering for
days because I remember that the last
time on the last map it was just pure
luck that I happened to come across it
pure unadulterated luck I know that it's
some sort of source of evil and at least
this thing gives off signals towards
whoa did I just hit a road for a second
there whoa who left all these nice
boards here thank you thank you goods
kind sir uh-oh my heat stone just ran
out well hopefully I'll be able to
survive a little bit I've got plenty of
wood sticks grass I'm good to go
but for the most part I still need a lot
of food basically I'm starving here see
that almost wiped me out I'm not gonna
be able to survive for long I'm hoping
that this doesn't just lead to a dead
end which it probably does excuse me
spiders I need these berries spiders
don't eat berries oh it's so cold oh
there we go let's drop the heat stone by
the thingy maybe I can keep the heat
stone in my back and I just need to do
the thingy with the thingy and uh then
go around with the other thingy
you know how it is you know you know how
it be you know would it be like I'll
just let that heat up for a while maybe
it'll get red-hot
oh damn it here's a dead end anyway hi
hi you spider [ __ ] you better back up
that's right I try hiss and run away
okay so this is a dead end up this way
but we managed to grab some boo-boo
look oh good yeah okay what is that what
was that way what was that spider doing
it looked scared it saw me and was like
oh no what I mess with markiplier yeah
that's what he did
yeah I'm so great Wow
I'm so great and everything I do
greatest youtuber ever greatest ever at
least I'm getting more food I mean
that's all I can really say but for now
I'm wandering away from where the cygnus
were before because I mean you know I
could I could gather the stuff and just
happen if I just so happen to come
across the pig king I could give it to
him well I mean I would rather just keep
wandering and try to find where I need
to go Maxwell's door what now well
there's another whole landmass over
there hello green mushroom hello berries
how you doing you doing good good good
to hear
hmm I'm headed back into the dense
forest again I really don't like this
area mostly because there's nothing
besides trees and I'm afraid to actually
get any of the trees because you never
know when a giant tree monster is gonna
pop out because somebody said that the
tree monster whoa
I know big bad time for that this bad
time I gotta make a fire get away you
spider douches I'm gonna get hurt from
the cold spider do should you get away
good good good good
you stay away this time we're gonna risk
some tree chopping here hopefully no
tree you wants to tangle with me because
I am fire to us gotta survive the dark
cool what is that
wait what is that light up there I never
seen a light like that before I'm gonna
go investigate it in just a second let's
make us up a torch II torch real quick
and then we'll be on our way never seen
the light like that so let's see what
happens hello what is you what is you oh
you're just damn fireflies never mind
I've seen lights like you before get out
of the way damn trees trying to get in
my way I don't know who they're messing
with
dad no no gonna eat some petals oh I see
petals hey heal your health miss but I
definitely needing I need to cook these
berries because they get a lot more food
hunger solving if they do yeah okay
we're full up there and I'll go ahead
and cook him up I know they don't last
as long when they're cooked but I figure
if I'm gonna be wandering around as much
as I am there huh ah worry about it I'm
not even gonna worry about it I'm even
gonna worry about
as heat stone is not getting hot enough
warm and cuddly for a rock it holds
their whoa yeah yeah yeah that's what
I'm talking about yeah come on get
hotter and it's top of the day let's go
let's go
and there we go okay it's a brand new
day a brand new way to go a brand new
thing to say hello blue mushroom oh no
my torch it just ran out
hey did that blue mushroom just go away
right before I could get it that son of
a [ __ ]
yeah whatever it doesn't matter there
sure are a lot of woods around here
found the edge and I could have sworn
that the last time I saw Maxwell's
portal II was in a sort of wooded area
but other than that I'm just at a loss
for what I'm supposed to do any more
grass yeah duh what Kate afraid way to
survive oh I've just entered another
biome apparently hello reeds am I in a
swamp how would I even be able to tell
it's all frozen over I'm really hoping
that eventually some whoa
what what was that where what was that
grumbling on the ground I bowed a bone a
bone where's Chester just ah how you
doing boy you're doing good here Chester
you take oh this you think it is you
take a dot you've taken a nighter
and you take the pine cones and yeah
that's good Thank You Chester come along
Chester good boy follow me ah yes just
ah it's good to see you I miss you
dearly I'm actually really happy now I
found the iPhone it's not a pig Hut look
at all these berry bushes oh man
what is that no no no what is that oh my
goodness I found like the berry good
hold mine this is incredible I think I'm
just ruining this guy's farm but this is
still awesome look at all these berries
I'm gonna leave like a king
look I yeah here you stupid turkeys
yeah gobble gobble gobble you so stupid
lucky
it says stupid it's silly cat hey piggy
it's a pig nama berries you [ __ ] you're
berry [ __ ] how could you take my
berries man I found like a whole pig
town look at all the berry bushes I'm
sure they won't mind I like Dave meaning
more than me
man this is incredible I can't believe I
found all the people oh oh well I'll
make my home here anyway because I mean
I'll make a real home this year this
will be my like my real place to go hey
buddy come back near the fire it's not
some warm
yeah I'll cook up some of these pine
cones there we go good enough all right
nice home you got here thanks for all
the berries she's so nice hi Brooke
that's Brooke that's Jamie hey guys yeah
you don't creep me out at all I bet
she's gonna happen because this is the
first Pig town I've ever seen is like
the pink pig king you're bi or something
I'm not entirely sure either way this is
really cool I like it a lot you know
it's really cool because I haven't
actually played this a lot on my own
outside of doing this let's play so I
don't I haven't had a chance to see all
there is to offer and apparently there
is a lot to offer
it's really cool to hang on I got to go
back and uh heat up my heat stone before
I go I should have dropped that off
earlier but I was kind of distracted by
all the awesome things that were
happening around me
all right heat son you heat up nice and
good there
there you go come on I need some more we
got a long way to go
mister heat stone glowing red I'm
assuming that's the most hot you'll get
so let's go away we'll come back here
just ah just ah do you get cold Chester
Chester Chester chesty chesty Chester oh
yeah
oh hello those are red are they red i
Mama's gonna break that probably just
look red cuz it's nighttime dumped him
give me your gold give me your gold oh
no I are red gold but I'm assuming it's
just as good yellow gold
donk young don't come don't come
thank you I don't really know what I
need the bill decides see I'm primarily
just focused on getting the heck out of
here as opposed to anything else but I
shall continue gold gold gold gold gold
that's enough gold for now I don't
really need any more gold and I can
always come back with I need to sell
food wait a minute these wait these
trees are different why are they
different they're bigger - I'm just
going on here like seriously I I'm I am
what what is that and what is that
obvious
what's the obelisk for what's an obelisk
more of a pyramid than an obelisk well
it hurt me no didn't even hurt me what's
over there hang on
I may have found something really
interesting if I'm not mistaken let's
see here could eat up these cuz they're
about to spoil well not even close this
boiling but you know I mean huh
is so weird I've never seen anything
like that what was the point of that was
there any point to that I have no idea
huh oh is that all about who's just a
bridge now whatever I guess it doesn't
matter I really wish that winner would
end soon hello
wait his dead body with no items around
it just a torch well this guy was really
useless he deserved to die I suppose Olo
found a graveyard lots of bones I'm
getting into some swoon nope nope nope
nope nope just ah run alright run away
just off we're gonna run out of heat ah
just uh good you better run why did they
break off the chase I have no idea but
I'm actually kind of lucky that they did
damn gotta go back to my little campfire
here because I do not have enough time
just ah come here just ah alright so
anyway we're about to hit nightfall here
so I will close up shop so anyway let me
guys let you guys let me know what you
think of what's going on here if you got
any clues as to what I should do or what
I should do better let me know in the
comments below so thank you again
everybody for watching
click the annotation for more videos
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
ah
later
the trader is out in wedding round
Duff and